stephen miller has been following this
since the beginning he's a former senior
white house advisor he joins us tonight
steven miller thanks so much for coming
on this seems like the simplest formula
ever every normal person hates crime
you'd really have to be kamal harris to
want more crime why aren't they running
on this
they're not running on it for the
reasons you identified joe biden is the
most unpopular president in american
history we should be looking at the
largest midterm victory for republicans
likewise in american history and instead
the forecasts are shrinking every single
day why because mitch mcconnell isn't
interested in running a national
referendum that says elect republicans
and in january we seal the border
we reform law enforcement to go after
criminals not republicans and we end the
war on america's children now what he
wants to do is hand pick candidates that
he thinks will like mitch and mitch will
like them and if that means we have 48
seats or we have 49 seats so be it he
gets to stay on as a majority leader
we are witnessing
in real time the greatest self-inflicted
wound we have ever seen if republicans
went out every day and said we have had
more illegal immigrants ever before this
year that have been recorded in world
history we have increases in crime in
our cities that no civilized nation has
ever seen and if you elect a republican
majority we will go in in january and we
will take the first funding bill and we
will attach to it a requirement the
border be shut
and a requirement that the fbi stop
attacking their opponents and start
locking up and breaking apart organized
crime in america and you say that in
every state and in every congressional
district in this country and you will
win a landslide like you have never seen
before but nobody wants to step up and
even make that promise that's exactly
right and actually there's precedent for
it the largest landslide in the history
of the american presidency was 1972 by a
candidate who did not win on charm but
won on law and order
and you can mock richard nixon all you
want but he was right 49
that's exactly right so again how dumb
are the people who run the party
well a lot of people have been drinking
the frank luntz kool-aid i was a
congressional staffer for almost a
decade i went to all of these
presentations so what they do is they
sit you down and they say well we ran a
message and it says that controlling
wasteful washington spending polls at 95
percent to which i would say everyone
else pulls at 95 percent i like cotton
candy
i think airplanes are really neat and
super cool um but i enjoy watching
movies on sunday none of that gets
anybody elected what gets people elected
is pushing messages where there's
nowhere to hide i'm for putting violent
criminals behind bars i'm for deporting
illegal aliens and you're not so i win
and you lose that's how you win
elections and how about rafael warnock
why don't you explain that video where
you seem to be committing spousal abuse
like why has that been memory hold that
guy's a u.s senator i thought we were
against that stuff maybe he'll come on
stephen miller great to see you tonight
thank you so much thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight